This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Denise Mazzo spent most of her adult life in a two bedroom apartment in Grenoble France. She raised two kids there while working at a factory and then a daycare. It's where she sowed Halloween costumes and dress suits for her family and settled in to her retirement. But old age has been difficult for her. In 2013, Denise, my grandmother, was diagnosed with Alzheimer's disease. That's reporter Mary Ann Renault.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。丹妮丝·马佐成年后的绝大多数时光，都在法国格勒诺布尔的一间两居室公寓里度过。她在那里抚养了两个孩子，先后在一家工厂和一家日托中心工作。她在那儿为家人缝制万圣节服装和正装，并安度晚年。但晚年生活对她来说并不容易。2013年，我的外祖母丹妮丝被诊断出患有阿尔茨海默病。说话的是记者玛丽·安·雷诺。
As the disease stripped away her memory and cognition, it also strengthened the world around her. She stopped driving, so we sold her car. And after decades of feeding her family, she stopped cooking. And her kitchen became another room to wander through. Once it wasn't safe or healthy for her to spend her days alone and disoriented, we moved my mean knees to a specialized memory care unit in a nursing home near Grenoble. Where she lives now is more like a hospital than like a home.
随着这种疾病剥夺了她的记忆和认知，它也剥夺了她与周围世界的联系。她不再开车，于是我们卖掉了她的汽车。在为家人做了几十年饭之后，她也不再做饭了。她的厨房成了另一个只能无目的地闲逛的房间。当她独自一人、神志不清地度过每一天不再安全、不再健康时，我们把外祖母转移到了格勒诺布尔附近一家疗养院的专业记忆护理区。她现在住的地方与其说是家，不如说更像是一家医院。
The doors are locked by keypads. The overhead lights are fluorescent. There's no living room, just a central space, with a row of scratched up tables and an area with medical arm chairs lined up in front of a TV. Her only private space is a small bedroom located in one corner of the ward, which she can't leave by herself. She tells us she's not home, but somewhere else. This is what most dementia care looks like in the Western world. For decades, society
房门由密码键盘锁上。头顶的灯光是荧光灯。这里没有起居室，只有一个中央空间，摆着一排刮花的桌子，还有一个区域，里面摆着排成一排、正对电视的医疗扶手椅。她唯一的私人空间是病区角落里的一间小卧室，她无法独自离开。她告诉我们，她不在家，而是在别的地方。这就是西方世界大多数痴呆症护理的现状。几十年来，社会
has dealt with people with dementia and other forms of cognitive decline by storing them away in un-stimulating, medicalized environments. But around the world, a new architectural movement is starting to change that old paradigm. Designing environments where people with dementia can live as normally as possible until the very end. Dementia has never been a welcome part of old age, but it wasn't always as despised or as feared as it is today. A couple of centuries ago, it was seen as a natural part of getting older. Like I say, it's not a good thing.
一直通过将患有痴呆症和其他形式认知衰退的人关在缺乏刺激的医疗化环境中来应对他们。但在世界各地，一场新的建筑运动正开始改变那种旧模式。他们设计出这样的环境：痴呆症患者可以尽可能正常地生活，直到生命的最后一刻。痴呆症从来都不是晚年中受欢迎的一部分，但它过去并不像今天这样令人厌恶或令人畏惧。几个世纪前，它被视为变老的一个自然过程。就像我说的，这不是一件好事。
No one's happy to start to have difficulty with memory and things like that. But there is a sense that it can be dealt with stoically kind of like all the things that happen with old age. That's Jess Ballinger, a historian of Alzheimer's in the United States. He says, at the turn of the 20th century, new devices like the microscope and the X-ray revolutionized Western medicine.
没有人会高兴自己开始出现记忆力困难之类的问题。但人们有一种感觉，即它可以像老年发生的种种事情一样，以坚忍的态度去应对。说话的是杰斯·巴林杰，一位研究美国阿尔茨海默病的历史学家。他说，在20世纪之交，显微镜和X光等新设备彻底革新了西方医学。
Now doctors could see previously hidden elements of the human body. By mid-century, this led to amazing leaps in treating and curing diseases like TB and polio. But there wasn't much progress when it came to dementia and Alzheimer's disease, the most common type of dementia. Well into the 20th century, doctors still had no way to diagnose Alzheimer's, let alone treat it. As one doctor put it in a 1980 news interview, he could listen to a patient's chest and hear congestion or see pneumonia on an x-ray.
现在，医生们可以看到以前隐藏的人体内部。到了本世纪中叶，这带来了治疗和治愈结核病和小儿麻痹症等疾病的惊人飞跃。但在痴呆症和阿尔茨海默病（最常见的痴呆症类型）方面，并没有取得太大进展。直到20世纪很长一段时间里，医生仍然没有诊断阿尔茨海默病的方法，更不用说治疗了。正如一位医生在1980年的一场新闻采访中所说，他可以听听病人的胸部，听到充血的声音，或者从X光片上看到肺炎。
And it's a very cut and dried situation where I can take your blood pressure and say, gosh, you've got high blood pressure, you've got hypertension. And these are very quantifiable and very defiantable. Alzheimer's disease is such as really only established at autopsy. After the fact, after the patient has expired. So instead of getting care,
这是一个非常明确的情况，我可以给你量血压，然后说，天哪，你血压高，你有高血压。这些都是非常可量化、非常明确的。而阿尔茨海默病只有在尸检时才能真正确诊。是在事后，在病人去世之后。因此，患者得到的不是护理，
people with dementia were simply locked away from broader society. For centuries, dementia patients had been sent to poor houses and jails. So instead of getting care, people with dementia were simply locked away from broader society. For centuries, dementia patients had been sent to poor houses and jails. But in the 19th century, many were moved to public mental hospitals. These institutions were designed to contain people, not care for them. Residents lived in crowded, sometimes unsanitary conditions, with limited access to fresh air and loved ones.
而是被简单地与广义的社会隔离开来。几个世纪以来，痴呆症患者一直被送往贫民窟和监狱。因此，患者得到的不是护理，而是被简单地与广义的社会隔离开来。几个世纪以来，痴呆症患者一直被送往贫民窟和监狱。但在19世纪，许多人被转移到公立精神病院。这些机构旨在限制人们的自由，而不是照顾他们。院民生活在拥挤、有时卫生条件恶劣的环境中，接触新鲜空气和亲人的机会十分有限。
When public mental hospitals were forced to close, a wave of nursing homes ushered in a new generation of people with dementia with nowhere else to go. Many of these nursing homes echoed the clinical harshness of their predecessors. Staff resorted to physical restraints, anti-psychotics, and sedatives to deal with patients, and residents could go months or years without stepping outside. All the while, Alzheimer's gained a reputation as an ever-approaching wave of human devastation.
当公立精神病院被迫关闭时，一波又一波的疗养院迎来了新一代无处可去的痴呆症患者。其中许多疗养院延续了其前身冷酷的临床作风。工作人员诉诸身体约束、抗精神病药物和镇静剂来应对患者，院民可能几个月甚至几年都无法踏出户外。与此同时，阿尔茨海默病获得了“步步紧逼的人类毁灭浪潮”的名声。
Well, most of us have never heard of it, but it kills 100,000 Americans every year. It strikes the elderly up to 2 million of them. It's called Alzheimer's disease. And with life expectancy increasing, it could become the worst health problem of the next century. Journalists, politicians, and even advocates and loved ones regularly described people with Alzheimer's as vegetables, as strangers, as shadows, as better off dead. Even sympathetic
嗯，我们大多数人都没听说过它，但它每年夺走10万美国人的生命。它袭击老年人，有多达200万老年人受其害。它被称为阿尔茨海默病。随着预期寿命的延长，它可能成为下个世纪最严重的健康问题。记者、政治家，甚至倡导者和亲属，经常将阿尔茨海默病患者描述为植物人、陌生人、影子、甚至觉得死了更好。甚至连充满同情心的
news reports presented the disease as it is often described, the funeral that never ends. I don't know why, and I don't know how, and I never dreamed that I would be in a condition like this never, never. But how do you feel it? That I'd rather be dead. As the terror of Alzheimer's spread, federal funding for Alzheimer's research also surged.
新闻报道也将这种疾病描述为人们常说的“永无止境的葬礼”。我不知道为什么，我也不知道怎么会这样，我做梦也没想到我会处于这种状态，绝、对、没、想、到。但你觉得它怎么样？我宁愿死。随着对阿尔茨海默病的恐惧蔓延，联邦对阿尔茨海默病研究的资金也激增了。
In the United States, it went from 4 million in the mid-1970s to 400 million by the year 2000. This explosion was driven by a fear-stoking publicity campaign. You have to show that people are suffering in order to get Congress to support research. And it works, works beautifully. That money was almost exclusively invested in finding a cure or treatment for Alzheimer's,
在美国，资金从20世纪70年代中期的400万美元激增到2000年的4亿美元。这场爆发是由一场煽动恐惧的宣传活动推动的。你必须展示人们在受苦，才能让国会支持研究。而这管用，效果好极了。这些资金几乎全部投入到寻找阿尔茨海默病的治愈方法或治疗手段上，
a strategy that hasn't panned out yet. And while it would be great to find a cure, very few resources have been used to study the lived experiences of people with a disease or to improve the spaces they inhabit. In fact, experts thought of nursing homes as a halfway technology, like the iron lung before the polio vaccine. Here's Jess Ballinger. There's a way in which no one intended this in the Alzheimer's movement, but in portraying the absolute devastating nature of this disorder, in making the claim that biomedical research was going to be the answer, there's a way in which
这一策略迄今尚未成功。虽然找到治疗方法固然很好，但很少有资源被用来研究患者的生活经历，或者改善他们居住的空间。事实上，专家们认为疗养院是一种“半途技术”，就像小儿麻痹症疫苗问世前的铁肺一样。说话的是杰斯·巴林杰。阿尔茨海默病运动中没有人有意这样做，但在描绘这种疾病绝对毁灭性的本质、在声称生物医学研究将是唯一答案的过程中，
they make caregiving like an afterthought. In all of this discourse, care becomes second-class. It becomes the thing you do because we've failed to have something really effective. As a result, many people would dementia live in spaces that are not designed with their specific needs in mind. For example, part of dementia's progression involves the loss of visual spatial skills. Studies have shown dementia patients might perceive a flat screen television as a hole in the wall or a paisley patterned rug as a fish pond in the ground.
他们把护理工作变成了一种事后才想到的事。在所有这些话语中，护理变成了次要的。它变成了因为我们未能找到真正有效的手段而不得不去做的事。结果，许多痴呆症患者生活在没有考虑他们特定需求的空间里。例如，痴呆症病程的一部分包括视觉空间技能的丧失。研究表明，痴呆症患者可能会把纯平电视误认为墙上的洞，或者把佩斯利花纹的地毯误认为地上的鱼塘。
They can interpret their own reflections in windows and mirrors as entirely other people. As I've seen at my grandma's nursing home, they can spend hours trying to clean what seems like a dirty tabletop that is actually just a speckled pattern. Throughout the West, most dementia care is like this. It's impersonal, clinical, and disorienting. But I kept hearing about this one place that's considered the exception to the rule. A living space whose anchoring philosophy is dementia-friendly design.
他们会把窗户和镜子里的自己当成完全是另一个人。正如我在外祖母的疗养院里看到的那样，他们会花几个小时试图清理看起来很脏的桌面，而那实际上只是一种斑点图案。在整个西方，大多数痴呆症护理都是这样的。它冷冰冰、公式化、令人迷失方向。但我一直听说有这样一个地方，被视为这条规则的例外。一个以“适老化设计”为核心哲学的居住空间。
It's called the Hogoike, and it's near Amsterdam in the Netherlands. Before the Hogoike existed, in its place there was a regular nursing home called the Hogoike. When the Hogoike opened in the 1970s, it wasn't yet the model for dementia-friendly design. It was six floors high, with corridors locked by keypants, handrails flanked the white walls, staff dressed in scrubs, medical needs, trumped, human ones. Ivan Van Umarangen worked on the Hogo-I staff. She told CNN that one moment in particular radically shifted her perspective on dementia care. It was 1993, and Yvonne's mother called to give her bad news.
它叫霍戈维克，位于荷兰阿姆斯特丹附近。在霍戈维克存在之前，它的原址是一家普通的疗养院，也叫霍戈维克。霍戈维克在20世纪70年代开业时，它还不是适老化设计的典范。它有六层楼高，走廊由密码键盘锁死，白墙旁有扶手，工作人员穿着刷手服，医疗需求压倒了一切。伊万·范·乌马拉根曾在霍戈维克员工队伍中工作。她告诉CNN，有一个特定时刻彻底改变了她对痴呆症护理的看法。那是1993年，伊冯的母亲打电话来给她一个坏消息。
Her father had died suddenly of a heart attack. One of the first things I thought was, thank God he never got to be in a nursing home. That's crazy, and I have to think that. I'm in the management of a nursing home, and I don't want my father to come there. That's crazy. It turned out her colleagues felt the same way.
她父亲突发心脏病去世了。我当时想到的第一件事就是，谢天谢地，他没有住进疗养院。这太疯狂了，我居然会有这种想法。我是疗养院的管理人员，而我却不想让我父亲来这里。这太疯狂了。事实证明，她的同事们也有同感。
They wanted their loved ones to receive the medical care they needed when they got older, but more importantly, they wanted them to lead normal lives, or at least as close to normal as possible. The Hogoai team agreed this couldn't happen in a non-descript hospital environment like the one they were running. With the envision was an approach that optimized environments for people with dementia instead of imposing sterile non-specific design, something that prioritizes the needs of dementia patients above all else. Remember those trippy patterned drugs? One principle of dementia-friendly design
他们希望自己爱的人在年老时能得到所需的医疗护理，但更重要的是，他们希望这些人过上正常的生活，或者至少尽可能接近正常的生活。霍戈维克团队一致认为，这在他们经营的那种平淡无奇的医院环境中是无法实现的。他们的构想是一种优化痴呆症患者生活环境的方法，而不是强加死板、非特定化的设计，这种设计将痴呆症患者的需求置于一切之上。还记得那些花哨的图案地毯吗？适老化设计的一个原则
is to minimize visual confusion with lots of natural lighting and uniform countertops and flooring. This school of architecture is still pretty niche, but it has a grand vision of a built and social environment that can support even sooth patients with dementia. When the Hogo-I began its redesign,
是通过大量的自然光、统一的台面和地板来尽量减少视觉混乱。这种建筑流派仍然非常小众，但它有一个宏伟的愿景：建造一个能够支持甚至安抚痴呆症患者的建筑和社会环境。当霍戈维克开始重新设计时，
it turned to a Dutch architect named Frank Vandillen. At that point, where we came from, it was a complete radical, new way of designing a nursing home. We start with questioning what is a lifestyle approach, what is a recognizable environment for people with Alzheimer. What is a safe built environment? How can we keep in touch with daily lives pleasures? Frank was hired by the Hogowak for their big redesign. At first, the team focused on small, affordable renovations to their existing buildings.
他们求助于一位名叫弗兰克·范迪伦的荷兰建筑师。当时，我们所处的情况是，这是一种设计疗养院的全新且激进的方式。我们从质疑开始：什么是生活方式方法？什么是阿尔茨海默病患者能够识别的环境？什么是安全的建筑环境？我们如何才能与日常生活中的快乐保持联系？弗兰克被霍戈维克聘来进行全面重新设计。起初，团队专注于对现有建筑进行小规模、负担得起的翻新。
They swapped out medical furniture for second-hand stuff and cheerfully decorated the living spaces. They installed a system of doorbells for private rooms and for Bade's staff from entering until after they'd run the bell. And they shrunk the wards from 30 years so people down to groups of 10 or 11 neighbors. Then in 2005, the Hogo White took a big leap forward. They tore down part of the original building and imagined something new in its place.
他们用二手货替换了医疗家具，并欢快地装饰了起居空间。他们为私人房间安装了门铃系统，并禁止员工在按铃之前进入。他们将每区30名病人的病房缩减为10到11人一组的邻里群体。然后，在2005年，霍戈维克迈出了巨大的一步。他们拆除了部分原有建筑，并在原址上构想了一些新东西。
A campus of buildings and spaces made specifically for people with dementia. In 2008, the new Hokoike opened. Instead of one big facility, it was a village, a neighborhood of homes, stores, cafes, streets, alleys, and parks. Everyone living there has advanced dementia, which means they can no longer live at home alone, and they're meant to live at the Hogoike until they die. But the Hogoike does not look or feel like a place of sickness and death. Feels normal, and that's what's so unusual about it.
一个专门为痴呆症患者建造的建筑和空间园区。2008年，新的霍戈维克开业了。它没有采用单一的大型设施，而是一个村庄，一个由住宅、商店、咖啡馆、街道、小巷和公园组成的社区。住在那里的人都患有晚期痴呆症，这意味着他们不能再独自在家生活，他们打算在霍戈维克一直住到生命尽头。但霍戈维克看起来或感觉起来并不像一个充满疾病和死亡的地方。它感觉很正常，这正是它与众不同之处。
I had heard about the Hogoike in my previous reporting on dementia care, and I've spent a lot of time watching my grandma's transition from her long time home to a new, unfamiliar holding space. I thought the Hogue-Wike sounded revolutionary. So this summer, I got a chance to see how it works in practice, in the messy, chaotic reality of dementia. I got to Hogoike on a bright windy June morning, and my guide that day was Eloy Venhal, one of the Hogoikes co-founders. The residents already said, in the sun, I see already a resident reading the news paper, or somebody reading the newspaper, because I'm not sure if it's a resident. We started our tour in the village's main courtyard.
我在之前报道痴呆症护理时就听说过霍戈维克，我花了大量时间看着外祖母从她居住了很长时间的家过渡到一个新的、陌生的暂住空间。我觉得霍戈维克听起来具有革命性。所以今年夏天，我有机会亲眼看看它在现实中是如何运作的，在痴呆症那混乱复杂的现实中。我在一个明亮多风的六月早晨到达霍戈维克，那天我的向导是埃卢瓦·芬哈尔，霍戈维克的创始人之一。居民们已经坐在阳光下了，我看到一个居民正在读报纸，或者有人在读报纸，因为我不确定他是不是居民。我们的参观从村里的中央庭院开始。
The waters of a large central fountain were gurgling and birds were chirping. On the benches and chairs scattered all around, early risers were already taking in the sun. Here, a Hoko-Wike residence benefit from a unique architectural concept, rings of privacy. In public places like the courtyard, they're in the outermost ring, totally
巨大的中央喷泉水流潺潺，鸟儿在呢喃。在四周散落的长椅和椅子上，早起的人们已经在沐浴阳光了。在这里，霍戈维克的居民受益于一个独特的建筑概念——隐私之环。在庭院这样的公共场所，他们处于最外层的隐私环，完全
exposure. Just by sitting down, they can encounter dozens of passing strangers and friends. That's where we found Niko, a 79-year-old Hogo-wike resident. Good morning. And then she went to the list. So I brought a journalist today. What? A journalist. We stopped to say hello and chatted for half an hour. Nico told me his hometown is base, where the Hogo Ike is located. It's quite sad. Yeah. He was a maintenance worker for Philips for 40 years.
暴露在外。只要坐下来，他们就会遇到几十个擦肩而过的陌生人和朋友。我们在那里遇到了尼科，一位79岁的霍戈维克居民。早上好。然后她去了名单那里。所以我今天带了一位记者来。什么？一位记者。我们停下来打招呼，聊了半小时。尼科告诉我，他的家乡是拜斯，也就是霍戈维克所在地。这挺让人难过的。是的。他曾是飞利浦公司的维修工，干了40年。
He collects coins. We're going to show him how long he saves a bucket. OK, and he is awake at 6.30 in the morning. His son lives in the nearby neighborhood and visits often with Nico's grandchildren. Recently, he told me he ran into an old high school classmate who was there to visit another resident. When Iloy tells him I'm there doing a story about the Hogue-Wike,
他收集硬币。我们要给他展示他把一个桶存了多久。好吧，他早上6点半就醒了。他的儿子住在附近的社区，经常带着尼科的孙子们来看望他。最近，他告诉我，他遇到了一个老高中同学，对方是来探望另一位居民的。当埃卢瓦告诉尼科我是来采访霍戈维克的故事时，
Nico lit up. He said, are you making a podcast about his good life here? How much? You can be convinced, that's you. lit up. With his warmth and his open smile, Nico reminded me of my grandma. The fact that Nico was here means he was probably also around the same stage of dementia as she was. But at my grandma's nursing home, she and other residents are often dressed in nightgowns by 6 p.m., and they wear embarrassing bibs for group meals. Here was Nico, with his shiny watch, dark jeans, neat sweater and black collared shirt.
尼科眼睛亮了。他说，你是在为他在这里的美好生活做一个播客吗？多少？你可以确信，那就是你。眼睛亮了。凭借他的热情和开朗的笑容，尼科让我想起了我的外祖母。尼科能来到这里，意味着他的痴呆症病情可能也和她处于同一阶段。但在我外祖母的疗养院里，她和其他居民通常在下午6点前就被穿上了睡袍，在集体用餐时他们还要戴上令人尴尬的围兜。而尼科戴着闪亮的手表、穿着深色牛仔裤、整洁的毛衣和黑色有领衬衫。
He seemed to be living out a different version of the same disease. One were his dignity and his appearance were left intact. The biggest design innovation at the Hogoike isn't the carpeting or the lighting fixtures or any advanced medical technology. It's how the Hogoike's design protects autonomy and allows people to live the same way they did before the advanced stages of dementia. the same way they did before the advanced stages of dementia. Every day, for example, someone from each of the 27 homes comes to the Hogo Yikes supermarket to collect groceries for the daily household meal, which is decided on by the residents. But unlike most grocery stores, there are no price tags and no money is exchanged at checkout.
他似乎在过着同一种疾病的另一种版本。在这里，他的尊严和外表都得以保留。霍戈维克最大的设计创新不是地毯、照明灯具或任何先进的医疗技术，而是霍戈维克的设计如何保护自主权，让人们能够像在痴呆症晚期之前一样生活。就像他们在痴呆症晚期之前那样生活。例如，每天，27个家庭中每个家庭都会派一个人来到霍戈维克超市，为日常的家庭餐采购杂货，这一餐由居民们自己决定。但与大多数杂货店不同的是，这里没有价格标签，结账时也不发生金钱交易。
The Hogo Yikes has conveniently edited out these complicated transactions, so residents can still enjoy grocery runs without worrying about calculating budgets or carrying change. Walking around, I noticed some residents smoking cigarettes outside of their homes. That seemed, well, weird to me, for a nursing home. But letting people smoke is part of the social
霍戈维克巧妙地删去了这些复杂的交易，因此居民们仍然可以享受采购杂货的乐趣，而不必担心计算预算或携带零钱。四处走动时，我注意到一些居民在房外抽烟。对于一家疗养院来说，这在我看来，嗯，挺奇怪的。但埃卢瓦说，允许人们抽烟是社会和物理架构的一部分。
and physical architecture, Eloise says. Residents use their furnished terraces however they like. In the same vein, if they want to wash their own clothes or make their own breakfast, each house has a washing machine, dryer, and functional kitchen at their disposal. Of course, the Hogo-I residents still need careful attention and clinical care. So at any given time, between one and three care workers with medical training watch over
居民们可以随心所欲地使用他们带家具的露台。同样，如果他们想自己洗衣服或做早餐，每栋房子都备有洗衣机、烘干机和功能齐全的厨房供他们使用。当然，霍戈维克的居民仍然需要细致的照顾和临床护理。因此，在任何特定时间，都有1到3名接受过医疗培训的护理人员照看
each household, helping to lead meal preparation or washing up. They will support you in your daily rhythm, so they will not wake you up. They will follow your rhythm. You can choose what you want to eat at breakfast. You make your own breakfast. They will make sure that what you're still able to do, they will support you with that. And they will only take over if you cannot do it anyway.
每个家庭，帮助引导准备膳食或洗碗。他们会支持你的日常规律，所以他们不会叫醒你。他们会遵循你的规律。你可以选择早餐想吃什么。你自己做早餐。他们会确保你仍然能够做的事情，他们会支持你完成。只有在你无论如何也做不到的时候，他们才会接手。
Walking around, it's impossible to tell by the clothes who's a visitor or who's a medical professional or a trained volunteer. Everyone is dressed in street clothes, no scrubs, no hospital counts. The staff are trained not to think of themselves as authority figures who correct behavior and treat symptoms, but to accept residents as they are and work to ensure their happiness. As Eloise showed me around, we passed by a
四处走动时，不可能从衣服上看出谁是访客、谁是医务人员或受过培训的志愿者。每个人都穿着便服，没有刷手服，也没有病号服。工作人员接受过培训，不把自己视为纠正行为和治疗症状的权威人物，而是接受居民的现状，并努力确保他们的快乐。当埃卢瓦带我参观时，我们经过了一个
terrace. The door was wide open and the staff member welcomed us into the house. And so, it was over three attempts. Come in! Thank you. Thank you. And we entered the living room and Eloi explained who I was and what I was doing there. Music was playing from a radio and one resident, Tricks, wandered over, singing along. I had to come to the beach. Yeah. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. Yeah.
露台。门大开着，一名工作人员欢迎我们进屋。所以，经过了三次尝试。进来！谢谢。谢谢。我们走进起居室，埃卢瓦解释了我是谁以及我在那里的目的。收音机里正播放着音乐，一位名叫特里克斯的居民走了过来，跟着哼唱起来。我得去海滩了。是的。我要再小心一点。是的。
No, I'm going to be a little bit more careful. Tricks joined in the conversation, dipping in and out of song to complain about the strong winds outside. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. La la la la la la la la la la la la. The staff member told us Tricks is a lover of music, especially classical music and songs from Amsterdam.
不，我要再小心一点。特里克斯加入了谈话，在唱歌和抱怨外面大风之间切换。我要再小心一点。我要再小心一点。啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦。工作人员告诉我们，特里克斯是个音乐爱好者，尤其是古典音乐和阿姆斯特丹歌曲。
It was one of those moments I loved to encounter with my grandma, a total suspension of social norms, and the joy that awaits us when we simply embrace the person in front of us. There was no shushing, no ignoring. The staff member understood Tricks' singing as part of who Tricks is, how she expressed herself, her needs, wants, pleasures, and displeasures, as she told Eloy, as long as there's a good atmosphere, Tricks enjoys herself. All together, people living at the Hogo Lake do something that is pretty unusual for people with dementia.
那是我最喜欢在外祖母身上遇到的时刻之一：社会规范的完全暂停，以及当我们简单地拥抱眼前的人时等待着我们的快乐。没有嘘声，没有忽视。工作人员理解特里克斯的歌唱是特里克斯本色的一部分，是她表达自己、表达她的需求、愿望、快乐和不快的方式，正如她对埃卢瓦所说的那样，只要气氛好，特里克斯就很开心。总的来说，住在霍戈维克的人们做了一件对痴呆症患者来说非常不寻常的事情。
They do what people do anywhere. They share meals, they make friends, they have pets, they fall in love, and they develop hobbies. So many hobbies. Near the main plaza, a billboard announces the weak's group activities, like music clubs, gardening, painting, sewing, biking, flower arranging, and happy hours. These activities offer another ring of privacy, this time of semi-privacy. Smaller groups are more structured and offer the possibility of making close friends
他们做人们在任何地方都会做的事情。他们一起吃饭，交朋友，养宠物，谈恋爱，培养爱好。有那么多的爱好。主广场附近的一个告示牌上公布了本周的小组活动，比如音乐俱乐部、园艺、绘画、缝纫、骑自行车、插花和欢乐时光。这些活动提供了另一个隐私环，这次是半隐私。较小的群体更有条理，并提供了结交志同道合的亲密朋友的可能性
with the same interests. Finally, we reached the innermost ring of privacy. The house is. We ran into Nico again outside his, admiring the family photos he had set out on his windowsill. He asks if we can look in his room because he invites us. Nico's been placed in this house alongside six other residents with similar traditional interests, like local news, folk music, and homey Dutch meals. I have over there. No, you're home.
。最后，我们来到了最内层的隐私环：房屋。我们在尼科的屋外再次遇到了他，他正欣赏着摆在窗台上的全家福。他邀请我们进去看看他的房间，因为他邀请了我们。尼科被安排在这座房子里，与另外六位有着相似传统兴趣的居民住在一起，比如当地新闻、民间音乐和温馨的荷兰饭菜。我有那边那个。不，你在家。
I'll post it in the evening. We followed Nico to his bedroom, the most Nico space in town. And it was his unequivocally. Nico had decorated it with pictures of windmills and photos of his family and famous Dutch soccer players. That's even my father-in-law. Yeah, that's the mother. And that is the mother-in-law's men's sons. Nico was proud to show us his space and his belongings.
我晚上贴出来。我们跟着尼科来到他的卧室，这是镇上“最尼科”的空间。这里毫无疑问属于他。尼科用风车的照片、家人的照片以及著名的荷兰足球运动员的照片装饰了它。那甚至是我岳父。对，那是母亲。那是岳母的男人们的儿子。尼科自豪地向我们展示他的空间和他的物品。
Many of them were gifts, like the model airplane given to him by a former Hogo-like resident and friend. Iloi pointed out, people seemed to enjoy giving him gifts. And Nico was humble, almost resistant to the idea that he could be so well liked. Well, that they are. But I have to... I have to. Yeah, you're a good guy.
其中许多是礼物，比如一位霍戈维克前居民兼朋友送给他的飞机模型。埃卢瓦指出，人们似乎很喜欢送他礼物。而尼科则很谦逊，几乎抗拒自己会如此受欢迎的想法。嗯，他们是的。但我得……我得。对，你是个好人。
I'm just getting a ride. I'm a good guy. I'm not a bad guy. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,ers. Nee, nee, nee, mensen vinden je aan, daar gaan geefsleden. Ja, denk ik. En ik voel dat al ook. of the most frequent questions from visitors. He tells them what he told me. The Hogue Wike is mainly funded by the Dutch government and receives the same budget per resident as any other skilled nursing home offering this kind of dementia care in the Netherlands. They just spend that money very differently. Some of those choices come down to the basics, like plumbing. Instead of building private bathrooms in every suite, like you'd find in a typical nursing home,
我只是搭便车。我是个好人。我不是坏人。不，不，不，不……（荷兰语交谈）这是访客最常提出的问题之一。他告诉他们他对我所说的话。霍戈维克主要由荷兰政府资助，每位居民获得的预算与荷兰提供这种痴呆症护理的任何其他熟练疗养院相同。他们只是把这些钱用在了截然不同的地方。其中一些选择归结为基础设施，比如管道。霍戈维克没有像典型疗养院那样在每个套房里建造私人浴室，
the Hogue Wike opted instead for two household bathrooms, similar to what you'd find in a lot of family homes. The designers also opted out of certain traditional nursing home features. Frank Fondillin, one of the Hogoike's architects, says they intentionally spread out social hubs to organically encourage physical activity instead of building a dedicated physiotherapy room. We designed an environment where people are more or less forced to go out to the supermarkets or to their hobby clubs or to the theatre. So they get their movement not because there is a physiotherapist in the house, but they get the movement to stay flexible because of the design and because of the urban design of the dementia village.
而是选择了两个家用浴室，类似于你在许多美国家庭中能找到的浴室。设计人员还放弃了某些传统的疗养院特色。霍戈维克的建筑师之一弗兰克·范迪伦表示，他们故意分散了社交中心，以有机地鼓励体育活动，而不是建造一个专门的物理治疗室。我们设计了一个环境，让人们或多或少被迫外出到超市、他们的俱乐部或剧院去。所以他们进行锻炼不是因为家里有理疗师，而是因为设计以及痴呆症村的城市设计，让他们为了保持灵活性而进行锻炼。
And at that point, we could skip, let's say, 200 square meters of physiotherapist room. And with that money, we can do something else. Another big question from visitors is about danger. The Hogo X design embraces everyday risk. A Hogo X resident could fall while roaming the neighborhood or they could jump in the fountain or they could cut themselves making a sandwich.
在那个时候，我们可以省去，比方说，200平方米的理疗室。用这笔钱，我们可以做点别的。访客提出的另一个大问题是关于危险的。霍戈维克的设计拥抱了日常生活中的风险。霍戈维克的居民在社区闲逛时可能会摔倒，可能会跳进喷泉，或者在做三明治时可能会割伤自己。
But according to Eloi, that kind of thing doesn't happen here, more than it does anywhere else. I think something really went wrong where we, as a society, accept that locking in people is better and safer, and that safety is a ball of life. That's our problem. That's our problem, our fear of more healthy people. But in our lives, all kinds of things also happen. You are here in Amsterdam. It's dangerous to walk around with all those bikes, trams, cars. We are tourists. It's a very dangerous city, but you still decide to come. Eloy pointed to one way the Hogoike measures the value of all the autonomy and socializing
但根据埃卢瓦的说法，这种事情在这里发生得并不比其他任何地方多。我认为我们在某处大错特错了，我们作为社会竟然接受将人们锁起来更好、更安全，并且将安全置于生活质量之上。这就是我们的问题。这就是我们的问题，我们对更健康的人的恐惧。但在我们的生活中，各种各样的事情也都会发生。你现在在阿姆斯特丹。带着所有那些自行车、有轨电车、汽车到处走是很危险的。我们是游客。这是一个非常危险的城市，但你还是决定来了。埃卢瓦指出了一种霍戈维克衡量它所鼓励的所有自主权和社交活动价值的方式。
it encourages. In the Netherlands, one in four nursing home residents with dementia is on anti-psychotics. At the Hogoike, that number is just one in ten. Experts predict the number of people living with dementia will more than double by the year 2050. With this in mind, a lot of people in charge of dementia care are looking to places like the Hogue Wike as a model for how to do things differently and to treat a person's social environment as an equally important part of their health care.
在荷兰，四分之一患有痴呆症的疗养院居民在服用抗精神病药物。而在霍戈维克，这个数字仅为十分之一。专家预测，到2050年，患有痴呆症的人数将增加一倍以上。有鉴于此，许多负责痴呆症护理的人正在将霍戈维克等地作为如何采取不同做法、并将人的社会环境视为其医疗保健中同样重要的一部分的模范。
There are now dozens of dementia villages and senior microtowns popping up in countries like Sweden, New Zealand, Canada, Denmark, and Australia. There are no dementia villages open yet in the US, though one is set to open in New Jersey in the next three years. But there's not a lot of hope that the village model will take off in a big way under a privatized health care system. Meanwhile, the Hogoike itself continues to evolve. Eloise says he hopes new regulations could allow to take another radical step forward, by
现在，瑞典、新西兰、加拿大、丹麦和澳大利亚等国正在涌现出几十个痴呆症村和老年微型城镇。美国目前还没有开放痴呆症村，不过其中一个预计将在未来三年内在在新泽西州开业。但在私有医疗保健系统下，人们对村庄模式能否大规模兴起并没有抱太大希望。与此同时，霍戈维克本身仍在不断发展。埃卢瓦说，他希望新的法规能允许其迈出更激进的一步，即
opening the only doors in the village that, with few exceptions, remain locked to residents. The entrance. That would mean letting residents come and go freely. Even people who like Eloise methods have questions about that one. Others say, Eloise, you're completely insane because they have advanced a mentor. They should be behind a locked door for their own safety. But I'm convinced about it. My measures that we should open the door.
打开村里除了少数例外仍然对居民上锁的唯一大门：入口。这意味着让居民自由进出。即使是赞同埃卢瓦方法的人对这一点也存有疑问。其他人说，埃卢瓦，你完全疯了，因为他们患有晚期痴呆症。为了他们自己的安全，他们应该呆在锁着的门后。但我对此深信不疑。我的措施是，我们应该打开那扇门。
The someday open door is what I thought about as I left the hogwike. Despite everything I'd seen in an experience, my mind still wandered to the worst-case scenarios. I guess phones or location devices could help keep residents from getting totally lost. But what if they had a stroke or a heart attack? What if they ran into someone unfriendly or even violent? Don't we owe the most vulnerable among us some protection from danger? And then I thought of my own family and my mommy Denise's husband, Papillon Jérô.
那扇总有一天会打开的门，是我离开霍戈维克时脑子里想的事。尽管我见证并经历了这一切，我的脑海里仍然不由自主地想到了最坏的情况。我想，电话或定位设备可以帮助防止居民彻底迷路。但如果他们中风或心脏病发作怎么办？如果他们遇到不友好甚至暴力的人怎么办？我们难道不应该对我们中最脆弱的人提供一些免受危险的保护吗？然后我想到了我自己的家庭以及我的外祖母丹妮丝的丈夫帕皮隆·杰罗。
He was diagnosed with Alzheimer's in 2008. He had survived internment during World War II and a life of poverty and manual labor. I remember as a child not knowing much about him other than what had happened to him, but I knew he loved to walk every day. Even when my mummy and puppy came to visit us and Rochester, Minnesota, he could not be kept from his walks. He spoke no English, he had Alzheimer's, at no point in his walk when he knew where he was, but we decided to put life above safety.
他在2008年被诊断出患有阿尔茨海默病。他曾在二战期间幸存於拘留营，并经历了一生贫困和体力劳动的折磨。我记得小时候对他的了解不多，除了发生在他身上的事之外，但我知道他喜欢每天散步。甚至当我的外祖母和外祖父来明尼苏达州罗切斯特看望我们时，也无法阻止他散步。他不会说英语，他患有阿尔茨海默病，在他散步的任何时候他都不知道自己在哪里，但我们决定将生活置于安全之上。
We put a hat on his head. We wrote down our contact information on a piece of paper and tucked it into his shirt pocket where it would stay unnoticed. And off he went, he walked for hours, to who knows where, without a map, alone in his mind, in a foreign place, he visited once a year. He walked, and he always came home. More with Marianne Renault after this. So we're back with reporter Marianne Renault. Hey Marianne.
我们给他戴上一顶帽子。我们将我们的联系方式写在一张纸上，把它塞进他的衬衫口袋里，这样就不会被人注意到。然后他就出发了，他走了几个小时，不知去向何方，没有地图，独自沉浸在自己的思绪中，在一个他每年只去一次的陌生地方。他走着，而且他总是能回家。广告之后，请继续收听玛丽·安·雷诺的节目。我们欢迎记者玛丽·安·雷诺回归。嗨，玛丽安。
Hi Roland. So one thing that struck me during this story is the history of the perception of dementia. Like it wasn't something that we feared as much in the past, which I found very surprising. Could you explain this a little bit more? I found that surprising as well when I learned that. Really, as we talked about in the piece, there was a time when dementia was conceptualized as inevitable. So it wasn't a disease, it was what we would call quote unquote, senility. And the thinking was, for example, that the mind is just the first part of the body that deteriorates with age, or that you're born with a certain cognitive reserve.
嗨，罗曼。所以在听这个故事的过程中，有一件事让我印象深刻，那就是人们对痴呆症看法的历史。就像过去我们并没有那么害怕它一样，我觉得这非常令人惊讶。你能多解释一下这一点吗？当我了解到这一点时，我也觉得很惊讶。真的，正如我们在节目中讨论的那样，曾几何时，痴呆症被概念化为不可避免的。所以它不是一种疾病，而是我们所说的“衰老”。当时的观点是，例如，大脑只是身体随着年龄增长而首先恶化的部分，或者你生来就拥有一定的认知储备。
And it just runs out. Like it was way more just a fact of a late symptom of being born. Late symptom of being born is an interesting way of being born. It's an interesting way to put it. So then what changed? One really big change comes along with a man named Dr. Robert Butler. And he is a part of the reason why we fear Alzheimer's so much now. Butler starts his career as a research psychiatrist. And over the evolution of his career, the goal is really to push back
它只是会耗尽。这更像是一个事实，是出生的一个晚期症状。“出生的晚期症状”是一种表达出生的有趣方式。这是一种有趣的说法。那么，是什么改变了呢？一个非常大的转变与一个名叫罗伯特·巴特勒医生的人有关。他也是我们现在如此害怕阿尔茨海默病的部分原因。巴特勒以研究精神病学家的身份开始了他的职业生涯。在他的职业生涯演变过程中，真正的目标是推翻
against stereotypes about the elderly and to make aging something that can be positive and dignified. So he coined the term ageism in 1968. He's the guy who came up with that concept and that word. And he won a Pulitzer Prize for his book, Why Survive Being Old in America in 1975? Well, he's really putting a fine point on it there, isn't he? Yeah, that's amazing. And the year he wins the Pulitzer, actually, he's also appointed to be the first director of the brand new National Institute on Aging,
关于老年人的刻板印象，并使老龄化成为一件可以积极和有尊严的事情。因此，他在1968年创造了“年龄歧视”（ageism）这个词。他就是想出这个概念和这个词的人。他在1975年凭借其著作《在美国变老：为何还要幸存》赢得了普利策奖。嗯，他在那里真的很明确地指出了这一点，不是吗？是的，这太惊人了。事实上，在他赢得普利策奖的那一年，他还被任命为全新的国家老龄研究所的第一任主任，
which was controversial at its conception because a lot of officials thought that it would just duplicate research on aging on strokes on heart disease that was already being conducted at these other existing NIH agencies. So Butler in his role as the first director, he wants to prove NIH's worth and he looks around and he sees the success of strident activism in the recent civil rights movement and in the women's liberation movement. And he also sees how the war on cancer strategy had an enormous impact for getting funding for the cancer institute. So he thought to himself, I need
这在它构思时备受争议，因为许多官员认为它只会重复这些其他现有NIH机构已经在进行的关于老龄化、中风、心脏病的研究。因此，巴特勒作为第一任主任，他想证明NIH的价值，他环顾四周，看到了近期民权运动和妇女解放运动中激进积极主义的成功。他还看到了对抗癌症策略在为癌症研究所获取资金方面产生的巨大影响。所以他心想，我需要
a disease. So you have Butler, he wants to make Alzheimer's the cancer of the NIA. make Alzheimer's the cancer of the NIA. That is, of course, just a challenger. And he says Butler's message to the public was this. We hadn't solved Alzheimer's because we hadn't adequately invested in a scientific solution to it. And he used to talk about this in interviews all the time. Alzheimer's disease, painful, devastating disease, it accounts for half of the people in nursing homes.
一种疾病。所以你有了巴特勒，他想让阿尔茨海默病成为国家老龄研究所的“癌症”。让阿尔茨海默病成为国家老龄研究所的“癌症”。这当然只是一个挑战者。他说巴特勒向公众传达的信息是这样的：我们没有解决阿尔茨海默病，是因为我们没有对它的科学解决方案进行足够的投资。他过去经常在采访中谈到这一点。阿尔茨海默病，一种痛苦、毁灭性的疾病，占了疗养院里一半的人口。
If we made a major commitment of research, we could bring that to an end. This is so interesting because, instead of aging being a natural process, the new thinking is that aging is a collection of accumulated diseases that can be solved in a laboratory, which is totally new thinking at this point. So what is the result of Robert Butler's campaign in this regard? Well, strictly speaking, in terms of numbers funding for Alzheimer's research absolutely boomed.
如果我们对研究做出重大承诺，我们就能结束这一切。这太有趣了，因为老龄化不再是一个自然过程，新的观点是老龄化是在实验室里可以解决的一系列累积性疾病，这在当时是一种完全崭新的思维方式。那么，罗伯特·巴特勒的这场运动在这方面带来了什么结果？严格来说，就数字而言，阿尔茨海默病研究的资金绝对呈爆炸式增长。
And then, of course, on the other hand, it's reputation also boomed, but it was this terrible reputation as what we call it a dread disease. At least in the US, Alzheimer's disease went from being a sort of niche, relatively unknown neurological condition to being a household name, something that people really thought of and felt as the disease of the century. And that campaign for awareness awareness largely disseminated stories of loss and grief, you know, really tragic stories. We all know that story because it's been told so many times through the media, but it's
然后，另一方面，它的名声也呈爆炸式增长，但它是一种可怕的名声，正如我们所说，是一种“可怕的疾病”。至少在美国，阿尔茨海默病从一种小众的、相对鲜为人知的神经系统疾病，变成了家喻户晓的名字，成为人们真正认为和感受到的是“世纪之病”的东西。那场提高意识的运动在很大程度上散播了失落和悲伤的故事，你知道，非常悲惨的故事。我们都知道那个故事，因为它在媒体上被讲述了太多次，但它是
the story of someone in the prime of life who's cut down by this terrible disease. Like that is part of what the meaning of Alzheimer's has a dread disease that we must combat. We must fight in the same way we have a war on cancer. I mean, I am so steeped in this thinking. I was grew up through all of this time where Alzheimer's became a thing you heard about and then became a thing you dread. I can't even think of that as being a problem. You know what I mean? So like tell me why is it a problem
某个正值盛年却被这种可怕疾病击垮的人的故事。这正是阿尔茨海默病作为我们必须与之抗争的“可怕疾病”的含义的一部分。我们必须像开展抗击癌症战争一样去战斗。我的意思是，我深深地沉浸在这种思维中。我在阿尔茨海默病成为家喻户晓的话题并随后成为人们畏惧之物的这段时间里长大。我甚至无法认为这是一个问题。你知道我的意思吗？所以，请告诉我，为什么他提高意识并让人门感到恐惧，这是一个问题？
that he raised awareness and made people fear this? I think for me, the problem really is what that thinking allows us to then do. So I don't think it's wrong and I don't think it's bad to be afraid of a disease that does something as extreme as changes your cognition, right? Like changes how you experience the world and how you understand the world and your relationships with people. I think that very clearly this is a disease that leads to certain kinds of losses and I think what feels
我认为对L我来说，真正的问题在于这种思维随后允许我们做什么。因此，我不认为害怕一种会做像改变你的认知这样极端的事情的疾病是错误的，也不认为这是不好的，对吧？就像改变你体验世界的方式、你理解世界的方式以及你与人的关系一样。我认为很明显，这是一种会导致某种特定损失的疾病，而且我认为感觉
challenging about this idea that people need to understand so deeply just how serious it is, just how devastating it is, is that that has a real impact on how we think of people with that disease. And it means that in sort of the public conception, we think of someone with dementia as someone with less and less value. We think of them as someone who can participate so much less in the world. And it's more so that I think if there was a way
关于人们需要深刻理解这个想法的挑战在于，它有多严重，有多毁灭性，这确实对我们如何看待患有这种疾病的人产生了真正的影响。这意味着在公众的观念中，我们认为患有痴呆症的人的价值越来越低。我们认为他们是在世界上参与度少得多的人。更重要的是，我认为如果有这样一种方式
for us to understand both the losses, but then also so much of the love and compassion that can come along with it too, but it's just that by really, really focusing on the losses, but then also so much of the love and compassion that can come along with it too, but it's just that by really, really focusing on the negative, it's allowed us to treat these people differently than we might otherwise. I mean, we can think about a disease like cancer, and what would it mean if we lived in a world where we thought that as soon as you had cancer, or as soon as you were sort of in a severe stage of cancer that you no longer had a self, you no longer had an innately human quality about it.
让我们既能理解损失，又能理解随之而来的许多爱与同情，但只是通过真正、真正地关注负面因素，这也让我们能够以不同于以往的方式对待这些人。我的意思是，我们可以想想癌症这样的疾病，如果我们生活在这样一个世界里会意味着什么：一旦你得了癌症，或者一旦你处于癌症的严重阶段，你就不再有自我，你不再具有任何内在的人性品质。
It's almost impossible to imagine that, but I do think that's really what we've done for people with dementia and Alzheimer's. We are still living with that stigma today, and I think that part of what makes that stigma so powerful is we don't verbalize exactly what it is that we think about people with dementia. But if you want to summarize that stigma kind of crudely, it is if you can't think, then can you be? I don't think that most people believe that people with dementia are capable of comprehensible expression. I don't think we think of them as being capable of having a meaningful sense of self. I don't think that we treat them as deserving of the kind of dignities, freedoms, and comforts
这几乎是无法想象的，但我确实认为这正是我们对痴呆症和阿尔茨海默病患者所做的事情。我们今天仍然生活在这种耻辱中，我认为这种耻辱之所以如此强大，部分原因是我们没有明确说出我们对痴呆症患者的确切看法。但如果你想粗略地总结这种耻辱，那就是如果你不会思考，你还能存在吗？我不认为大多数人相信痴呆症患者能够进行可理解的表达。我不认为我们认为他们有能力拥有有意义的自我感。我不认为我们对待他们配得上那种尊严、自由和舒适
that we feel that every human has the right to. Your whole story is about these villages, which represents a kind of progress in dementia care. Are there any other things that give you hope about how we treat people with the disease? I mean a lot of what I've seen and learned through my reporting is how much basic human communication can be part of the solution. And what can get tricky is sometimes that is not basic social convention. So we can think about tricks for example in the story who was singing and who communicates through singing and is also present in conversation through singing. And that was a moment where just by paying attention and knowing her, there was communication happening.
我们觉得每个人都有权拥有。你的整个故事都是关于这些村庄的，它们代表了痴呆症护理的一种进步。还有什么其他事情能让你对我们如何对待这种疾病患者抱有希望呢？我的意思是，我在报道中看到和学到的大量东西是，基本的人类沟通如何能成为解决方案的一部分。棘手的地方有时在于，这并不是基本的社会习俗。所以我们可以想想故事中的特里克斯，例如，她通过歌唱来沟通，并且也通过歌唱参与到对话中。在那一刻，只要注意并了解她，沟通就在发生。
But it required us to sort of halt our beliefs on how a group of adults is supposed to have a conversation together or what that looks like. So a lot of it is stuff like physical touch and having conversations with people with dementia that they can actually participate in, not just asking, do you remember this? Do you remember that? The dermatologist and basting talks about open-ended questions.
但这需要我们停止对一群成年人应该如何一起进行对话的看法，或者这应该是什么样子。所以很多事情都是身体接触之类的事情，与痴呆症患者进行他们实际上能够参与的对话，而不仅仅是问，你还记得这个吗？你还记得那个吗？皮肤科医生兼基础研究员谈到了开放式问题。
Can you show me this? There's these ways of looking to the essential of how human communication works, and we don't actually require hyper cognition to understand each other and to value each other, and I really think that we live in a world and in a future where there is so much uncertainty and disorientation and vulnerability and resilience, and people with dementia are experts on all those subjects.
你能把这个展示给我看吗？有这些方法来寻找人类沟通工作本质的核心，我们实际上不需要高度认知来相互理解和重视对方，我真的认为我们生活在一个充满不确定性、迷失方向、脆弱性和韧性的世界和未来中，而痴呆症患者是所有这些主题的专家。
I think that we have so much to learn and it just requires us taking a step back and thinking more simply about human relationships. Well, thank you, Mary Ann. It's been a really interesting work on the story with you. And so thanks for bringing it to us. I appreciate it. Thank you so much for letting me tell it with you guys. Thank you. Thank you.
我认为我们有太多东西需要学习，这只需要我们退后一步，更简单地思考人际关系。好的，谢谢你，玛丽安。和你一起做这个故事真的很有趣。谢谢你把它带给我们。我很感激。非常感谢你们让我和你们一起讲述它。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. 99% Invisible Was Produced To Speak By Marianne Renault, edited by Chris Barube, sound mixed by Martin Gonzales, music by Swan Rihale, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Our Executive Producer is Kathy too. Delaney Hall is our Senior Editor Kurt Colstead is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Jason Dillion, Lashemondon, Jacob Moltenado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars.
谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。《99% Invisible》由玛丽安·雷诺（Marianne Renault）制作，克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzales）混音，音乐由斯旺·里哈莱（Swan Rihale）创作，格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）核实事实。我们的执行制片人是凯西·图（Kathy Tu）。德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·Johnson、维维安·李（Vivian Leigh）、杰森·迪利昂（Jason Dillion）、拉什蒙登（Lashemondon）、雅各布·莫尔泰纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Moltenado Medina）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。
The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence, special thanks this week to Lotta Van Holland, Morton Greggerson, Johannes Peterson, and the entire team at the Hocoike. 99% of visible is part of the Citrus and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find links to other Citroën shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《99% Invisible》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作，特别感谢本周的洛塔·范·霍兰德（Lotta Van Holland）、莫顿·格雷格森（Morton Greggerson）、约翰内斯·彼得森（Johannes Peterson）以及Hocoike的整个团队。《99% Invisible》是Citrus和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼北面六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。您可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜欢的其他 Citrus 节目的链接以及 99PI 的每一集往期节目。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。